[Music]
hey everybody its charlie this is gonna
be my episode 6 video if you're finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the west-world
episodes in obviously spoiler warning if
you haven't seen it yet because they did
give away some big turns in the plot
very heavy mythology episode that also
filled in some moments from earlier this
season with new context given the big
twist at the end so let's just do top 10
WTF and Easter eggs as we go along
number 10 they wrap up the Shogun world
storyline with Musashi's samurai battle
totally badass
I think people were really happy to
finally see them do a genuine battle
like this like they tease that he was
modeled after the most famous samurai in
history so as they're fighting that's
why he grabbed the opponent's sword and
started fighting with it because that's
his signature style then I love the way
that he ends himself too they deal with
a sense of honour that they have in
Shogun world you don't really see in
West world where there's so much
backstabbing so he ends himself after
Musashi chops his hand off and it's also
sort of a parallel for Rinko Kikuchi
'he's character who cuts her heart out
after her daughter has died like her
daughter is her heart so she cuts it out
and she's taking it back to her home to
burn it so number 9 I think that that
storyline is nice foreshadowing for mave
storyline also the same thing with the
man in black and his daughter so a lot
of ideas about parents children and
people wanting to leave the park not
wanting to leave the park this is her
home we choose to stay here so be
prepared for potential mave twists but I
think this mountain here is meant to be
Mount Fuji it looked beautiful I don't
know where they filmed these scenes but
I assume a little bit of CG was involved
for some of these backgrounds because I
don't think they actually went to Japan
to film this but number eight hardcore
Teddy is now the best Teddy so the way
Teddy has been changed is they
essentially changed his personality so
much so that he says forget about that
other teddy I love the way that Dolores
is kind of disconcerted by that she's
the one that did this but now she's not
quite so sure about what she got when he
changed that look on her face is so
beautiful then he straight-up executes
the guard without a second thought to
speed things along don't worry we'll
find your father everybody on the train
right now if you don't remember exactly
how they changed Teddy in last week's
episode they
ranked his cruelty to maximum the other
sliders that they also crank to maximum
were decisiveness which is why he moved
so quickly when he decided to end that
tech like ok time to go now but also
this stat called a perception which is
his ability to take in new information
and recontextualize the way he thinks
about things given new input so that's
how he learns that Dolores has been
changing him
that's why later in the episode when
he's talking to Dolores for the second
time on the train and she's like
remember how we used to talk about
leaving this place and he says you know
I used to think that I would never leave
but I suppose you changed that too so
he's becoming more aware and awakened to
this new reality and a much faster pace
than he was before but one of the really
cool things foreshadowing for future
Teddy's storyline is is that Lisa joy
one of the co-creators of the show said
that James Marsden's storyline from here
on out was the one that she was most
excited about because the show has kind
of wasted him as a character for the
last couple of seasons because James
Marston is a great actor but they
haven't given Teddy a whole lot to do so
from here on out
Teddy is supposed to be totally badass
number seven the man in black thinks his
daughter is a host controlled by four
part of this game you're pretty sick
forward
you'd make a host out of my daughter but
I think her actions proved to him that
she's real so he comes around but he
seems very mistrustful
of everything around him but I do love
the way that she dispatches that
honeypot most of their conversation
there is just to let you know what her
skills are and the fact that she's able
to survive on her own set it for the
twist that came later when he bailed on
her so number six that was actually more
fun he tricks her into thinking they
have this father/daughter understanding
well I guess we're leaving in the
morning then we're all square we're
gonna be father/daughter we'll be a
family again
then she wakes up they're all God son of
a [ __ ] I think this was a fairly
predictable twist like there's no way
he's gonna leave the park also
foreshadowing like I said possibly form
a v' storyline made has been baking on
her daughter just completely embracing
her as her new mother so we'll talk
about that in a second - the whole idea
that not everybody wants to leave the
park like Dolores keeps saying not
everybody is destined for the valley
beyond number five the new Hardcore
della security team that comes in
after Charlotte captures Abernathy
they're awesome I love the way that
Ashley reacts to them to one he comes in
and basically it says that Ashley is
crap at his job we're taking over now
don't worry we don't need your help and
on top of that he makes fun of Ashley
his name because that's a name you would
typically give to a girl so he's
basically just saying that Ashley is a
crap human being so they basically have
what you would think of as like the evil
GI Joe version of add ellos team like
they have all the cool weapons they have
text they can do what the text inside
ellos can do and we'll see what ends up
happening to them because Delores is now
infiltrating the Mesa so I think you
know we're gearing up for a battle
between this you know supposedly
hardcore security team in the hosts but
Ashley's reactions to all this is just
priceless like one he reacts to
Charlotte like wouldn't it been helpful
if he would have told me about all these
secret plans because I'm the head of
security she's like you know whatever
like she doesn't care about him at all
then he just sort of laughs at the
security team when they started making
fun of him like okay whatever I'll just
roll along with this so you can see that
they want you to be sympathetic to some
of the Della's people like Ashley seems
like a genuinely good person so I'll be
interested to see if he actually ends up
trying to help out Delores at some point
but number four Maeve is reunited with
her daughter only to find out she has
another mother and does not remember her
and they also have this similar scenario
that starts to unfold with the ghost
nation giving her all these flashbacks
so I love the way that they cut it from
this really hopeful tone like she's
getting really excited they shoot it
really beautifully but then as she walks
up there's this look on her face this is
beautiful mixture of confusion horror
and then rage when she realizes the
reality of the situation so if it wasn't
clear what's going on here is that the
ghost nation looks like they're part of
Dolores's rebellion he says that they're
on the same path so they're not trying
to kill her like they were in the
original loops they're trying to get her
to join him and she doesn't want to have
anything to do with that just like she
didn't want to have anything to do with
Dolores's uprising but I think the
moment that we're headed for here is is
that Maeve's daughter potentially might
not want to leave the park or might not
be ready to and she won't be able to
take her with her so she'll have to bury
her heart the way that Rinko Kikuchi did
in a fashion like you know we're all
talking about metaphors here because
remember Maeve can control
any of the host minds so she could force
them to do anything that they want but I
don't think that she's going to force
her daughter to come with her if she
doesn't want to go number three Bernard
and Elsie inside the cradle cut into his
skull to take out his memory core
without turning off his pain sensitivity
so he feels it just like a normal person
it's a pretty harrowing scene just
seeing him scream there and then go
lifeless as essentially his brain is
pulled out in interfaced into the matrix
she also has a couple lines of dialogue
that foreshadow a big twist with him
possibly getting a different memory core
in next week's episode or the week after
that maybe when she says even if she can
put Humpty Dumpty back together that
doesn't mean that she's going to be able
to make Bernard like he was before like
she can't automatically undo all the
damage that was done so I think this is
where we're getting to the idea of
Bernard swapping consciousness swapping
into different bodies they also take
great care to remind you of the scenes
where he grabs that red human memory
core from the secret lab they cut that
when he was getting ready to enter the
matrix so you have someone else's human
consciousness and Bernards sort of
getting mixed up in the same scene here
because of that big scene at the
beginning of the episode number two
though speaking of Dolores she uses the
train as a first strike in an
infiltration of the Mesa to get her
father so that's just obviously teeing
up a big battle they'll go down in next
week's episode but it was totally badass
and I love the way that Teddy gave that
one bullet to the tech this is the last
of my mercy best use it quick like I
said hardcore Teddy is the best version
of Teddy but number one obviously the
big reveal that Bernard goes into you
know this sort of collective backup of
the park itself and all the hosts
consciousness in finds Ford inside the
mariposa but I think what they're
implying here is that before Ford
initiated his journey in tonight
protocol at the end of season one and
had Dolores kill his human body he had
uploaded his consciousness into the
cradle here and has been using it to
control all the systems of the park
orchestrating all the things that we've
been seeing going down and it also
explains how he's using the other hosts
to speak to the man in black whenever he
wants to so if it wasn't clear in the
earlier episodes they actually said that
the cradle is where they store all the
backups for
host so all these people that you see
walking around here like you see Dolores
on her loop this is essentially a
version of the park that they could just
read up load to all the hosts and turn
everything back to normal but they said
in last week's episode in the future
timeline after all the Delos people come
to the park at the end of this you know
two-week period that the cradle had been
destroyed so just keep that in the back
of your mind that the backups will
eventually be destroyed but right now in
the past we see that Ford is alive
inside there controlling everything the
real twist I think with that
conversation that Dolores is having with
this person here that seems like Bernard
at the beginning of the episode I think
is the tip-off that she is actually
going to orchestrate events so that the
show can bring back Arnold this is a
test that we've been conducting many
times for fidelity just like the James
dello seen a couple episodes ago but let
me know in the comments what was your
favorite moment from the episode and
what do you think that Ford is going to
do with Bernard now that he's inside
this collective consciousness he's
obviously going to explain what's been
going on this whole time post all your
theories in the comments there'll be
some more ant-man in the wass posting
later tonight click here for all my
other Westworld videos and click here
for brand new Game of Thrones thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]